Hey,
what's going on?
It's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast and
just checking in on you,
just checking in to see how your week's going and that type of shit.
And uh,
you know,
we do on this podcast issues.
He just sold freckles here talking by himself,
acting like a fucking maniac,
solving world problems by himself.
No one to debate it.
So it all makes sense.
Um,
and every once in a while I have a special guest,
which I do.
I do have a special guest and my special guests as promoted like a week ago or
whatever on my podcast is,
uh,
the one and only Dave emailage a drumming sensation.
Teachers sensation,
human being sensation owner of plenty of t shirts.
Dave,
what's going on dude?
Happy to be her brother.
Yeah.
Welcome to the podcast.
I told you before we started,
I made a major fuck up on my last podcast.
Yes,
I called the band the specials.
The smiths.
Okay.
And oh boy.
I know that is not good at all.
And I was going on and on about how much I love this set and all that and I
fucked up and I want to apologize to everybody in the,
actually met the lead singer of the band and the guitarist and the lead singer
of the band,
uh,
said,
he real quick,
it was just like,
all right,
I love the way you say the word cat.
You say it right in.
I was just,
it was like the greatest compliment ever.
Absolutely.
It's like when my buddy Joe de Rosa was in Scotland in a bar at like four in the
morning,
and some Scottish guy said too,
it was like,
Joe,
you can fucking drink.
And he's just like,
it was like the greatest compliment ever.
So I've got to apologize to them.
Okay.
It's,
it's,
it's my fault.
The fucking music I listened to in the eighties you know,
I was in the fucking metal and all these skater guys and everything up the
street.
My brother hung out with a w stopped her medicine all around bar.
I'm like,
these guys aren't singing about the devil.
They're not wearing women's clothes.
I'm not listening to these guys.
I mean I always,
you know,
I was very,
I was closed off back then,
you know,
so,
um,
you know,
so you saw it,
you saw when I,
I've been taking lessons with you for about one a year and a half or so.
Then you come in and longer than that man.
Yeah,
we used to write is it felt like 10 for you
going in there.
I came in there like the crypt keeper,
like I'll fucking
crunched over and shit,
holding the sticks,
wrong
forums,
everything all jacked up and I got to tell you like,
um,
on here,
besides the fact that you're a good friend of mine,
you're on here because you have a new,
uh,
a new drum instructional video route called getting out of your own way.
True.
Which I actually got to watch a lot of,
uh,
last night and it's all this stuff,
you know,
that you've been teaching me,
which was I was basically fighting the kit and yourself.
Yeah.
I was like,
yeah,
it was all crunched over holding the sticks wrong.
I was just playing uphill.
Yes.
Nothing was at the right level.
And uh,
for the drummers out there who listened to this podcast,
I cannot tell you like this stuff that you showed me just getting me to sit up
straight,
hold the sticks right and have shit where I can hit it,
do to my body type.
Yeah.
It's made so much stuff that used to be really difficult,
like borderline effortless now however,
I still suck because at the end of the day,
no matter how much you teach me to sit up straight,
I am still a at the mercy of the talents that I was blessed with.
But I'm,
but I'm still,
you know yeah.
But it's a whole different ball game.
The one I first saw you man.
I mean cause you work your ass off too.
You know it's like I can show you show people how to do things but at the don't
put in the work,
nothing's going to change.
You know,
you work your ass off.
So I'm a lunatic Dave.
Yeah,
I know.
I get into shit.
That's my point.
That's exactly what I'm saying.
That's why I always stayed away from hard drugs because I would have like,
I'd have like a fucking monogram coke spoon.
I would just be,
I would be a coke heads coke head.
I know if I did it.
So I try to,
I try to send it into a positive areas.
So a,
it's a good plan.
Well,
look,
I gotta ask you,
I don't know if I've ever even talked to this talk to you about this,
where it's just like,
see,
you grew up in northern California.
You said,
hell of this.
Hello Dad.
I'm sure.
Right?
Yes.
I got made fun of a lot when I moved to La Sacramento Kings Fan.
Maybe
I did see the sharks a bit,
uh,
for hockey when I was a fuck,
I just realized I,
this fucking leather chair,
if this is going to make a bunch of noise when I'm moving around like that Benny
Hill sketch,
you'll see that one where he wanted the leather pants,
one of the great sketches.
No,
every time he had to deliver a line,
he would walk across the room and it was just the sign of his leather pants and
he was sitting down crossing his legs and then the other person would talk
fucking genius.
I'll have to check it out.
Um,
anyways.
so when you start,
what made you like want to play drums?
Like what got you started is what band?
Oh,
what band?
You know,
I don't know if there was a,
I mean I had a friend who was taking drum lessons and I like slept over at his
house.
I was like nine or something.
And he's like,
oh my drum teachers coming over to give me a lesson.
And I was like,
oh,
hang out and watch.
And then I was like,
oh,
this seems fun.
And then I sat down and I could just kind of do it.
Like it was like he had that gift.
Yeah.
It was like,
oh dude,
I can kind of do this.
And uh,
I'd never really had that experience before,
so I just immediately got hooked.
Uh,
and so I was like nine or 10.
So this is like 93 94.
Right.
So this is like God,
I'm old when I was 25 and 26.
Yeah,
that's crazy.
Yeah.
But this is like old dude.
But remember when we were setting each other youtube clips about uh,
uh,
um,
I sent you that faith,
no more clip and you sent me the was a skid row.
Is that what it was?
I don't remember.
Probably skewed.
I love skid row.
It was that,
it was like SNL performances and it was like,
oh my God,
skid row on fucking SNL and it was like the same year and it was like check out
the,
we were talking about the shift in music like right around 91 92 I think it was.
And it was like how like right when grunge and all this stuff was coming out and
it was just like hair metal to grunge was just like,
you were like,
what the fuck is it was it was abrupt?
Yes.
It was like a how a lot of divorces go down in la where there's like the day
after the prenup expires,
Bam,
divorce papers.
Like,
that's the way the musical shift was.
But like as a kid,
I was,
I at that point like,
uh,
what year was that?
When,
when,
I think it was 91.
[inaudible] 92.
Yeah.
And that's good roll album.
I fucking love that out.
Right.
And they were crushing.
Crushing,
yes.
And I was like,
Sebastian voice was just like,
just one of the great front men.
Yes,
absolutely.
Of all time.
And I had,
I didn't see that shift in music coming.
I think away way a lot of those bands didn't where I,
cause I remember when Nirvana came out,
I was like,
what the fuck is this?
And I couldn't really even hear how good a band they were or that first video
they had the teen spirit when he was like doing like,
uh,
basic solo and he was kind of acting like he was doing the tap on Solo and was
clearly making fun of all the guys that I like.
Totally.
I was like,
dude,
fuck these guys,
fuck this band.
And it wasn't until I saw them on unplugged and I got in Utero and everything.
And I was just like,
wow,
these guys are making like,
this is a beautiful album.
And I,
and it took me,
but it took me like two and a half years of,
of being like,
wait a minute.
The 80s or over?
Yeah,
because I'm old now because you have that shit juxtaposed right next to each
other and you're growing from spandex and lipstick and straightened hair to like
flannel shirts.
And the Glam thing was only about three years.
Okay.
It was right around 85,
86 everybody got there,
started dressing like men again around 87 88 they had a round table meeting and
we're like,
look,
stop blowing up the hair.
Let's go back to,
let's try to get a little more almond brothers here and a little less,
uh,
grease,
whatever the fuck they were doing.
But so yeah,
so that was the scene I was growing up and when I started playing was what we're
talking about right now.
So you missed all,
all this shit.
You would just,
you know,
10 years old.
I mean,
I definitely listened to a Shitload of Phil Collins when I was like a little
Katie's Phil Collins or row,
like the later stuff that everyone makes fun of.
Well,
Sassoon audio.
Yeah.
I mean,
you know,
yeah.
I wasn't like listening to that song specifically,
but like to share about that
a little bearded 10 year old days dancing around sue sue,
sue audio.
I did come out of the womb with a beard by the way.
Oh you did?
Yeah.
Just always been Harry.
Yeah,
that's what it is.
That's why he went to the drums.
You were fucking animal.
That's true.
I've heard that more than once.
Um,
did you,
uh,
so then when,
when,
when you,
uh,
when all that grunge stuff came out,
yeah.
Was that just sort of music to you as opposed to no,
no.
Like being like,
oh,
this is a,
you weren't old enough to realize like,
wow,
we just went from this to that now.
Not at all.
That's what I'm saying is like,
because that happened.
I remember listening to sir,
it's actually funny like saying this,
like I listened to so much Phil Collins,
but I would hear like new wave stuff or,
or 80 stuff like tears for fears and be like,
oh,
gross.
And now I love law of that stuff.
Right.
Um,
but at the time it was like the least cool shit ever,
you know?
So I went back to the eighties a bunch of times going,
Oh wow,
this man was actually pretty good.
Yeah.
And it's in a lot of that stuff is so interesting and esoteric and weird ways
that you check it out now.
And some of it's aged poorly,
but some of it's aged in like a really cool way.
Yeah.
I didn't like a lot of just the sound.
Shit that came out in the 80s whatever that sound was.
I saw somebody sent me a video,
you know,
about how they came up with that,
that sound for the drums,
right.
That was the Phil Collins [inaudible] sent me.
Yeah.
That was just a complete accident where there was a Mike on in this studio and
somebody played a Phil.
Yeah.
And it was,
it was,
it was in the control room or something.
Yeah.
Phil Collins was apparently the,
there's various stories,
but apparently Phil Collins was playing drums on a one to Peter Gabriel's solo
albums.
Um,
and he was trying out fills or whatever and someone hit the talkback Mike.
Uh,
so if you,
you know,
for people who haven't recorded in a recording studio,
when you're in the control room,
you hit the talkback Mike and they,
you can then hear what the person's saying,
uh,
or if you're in the studio tracking drums,
you can't hear what anyone's saying and the control room,
so they have to hit a talk back mic,
a button so you can hear what's going on.
And basically they went to talk to Phil and they hit the talk back Mike and he
played a drum fill over that and the,
the,
the talkback Mike picked it up and just got super blown out and they were like,
whoa,
that was crazy.
It was like a complete accident.
And that's how that gated,
like Peter Gabriel was like,
I like that sound.
Yeah.
And then,
which is probably,
I imagine a cool sound initially.
And then it,
it was just overused and then,
and that's how everything happens now.
It's totally like in vogue again,
like everyone,
I mean it's sort of starting to get overused now,
but it just went through a whole thing over the past five years where that was
super hip again.
Let's go on in my business right now where they just,
they,
I don't know what they just rebooting everything that I already watched that
going there,
pointing through imdv to be like,
is this guy still alive?
Do you think he wants to do a WHO's the boss again?
And fucking [inaudible] who's the blog?
So I'm trying to think of something more obscure than that.
Um,
she's the sheriff,
is that a show?
That was a show and the only reason why I know that is because a friend of mine
was on it for a couple episodes and he said it one night and it was just like,
dude,
that's one of the great fucking references.
I don't even know what that is.
That was a,
uh,
that beautiful woman who was on,
um,
Suzanne Somers.
Mm.
Um,
she started it and evidently she was a sheriff.
She's the sheriff and she was just this hottie who was the sheriff.
Everybody had to listen to what she did it,
you know,
I think it was for like people who are into like dominatrix and like women tell
them that piece of shit and they're under arrest.
It was sort of something,
there was an underlying sexual thing to everything that was done back then.
You know,
you can't do any of that now.
Now she'd be a fucking hero,
you know,
whatever the fuck I would have or that,
the pendulums completely swung the other way now.
So every guy's a fucking ticket,
his dick out and peeing on a plant,
blocking a door.
And women are all like,
fucking Joan of arc.
Um,
there's no middle ground.
There's no middle ground.
That's what it is.
We're going to go from not listening to women to not vetting any of them and
then saying every fucking guy's a complete piece of shit through some of the
shit that's coming.
Like some of these guys got friends of mine now.
It's like literally ex-girlfriend's who are mad that they're famous now.
Totally just coming out,
going like,
oh,
lives get ruined.
They're like,
man,
I don't like you anymore,
so I'm going to ruin your day.
I mean,
well,
the fact that this,
if you're,
if there's gonna be no due process,
I mean,
who is safe?
Yeah,
no one.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
Was emotionally abusive and say,
I've gotta,
I've gotta emotionally abused and like at least 85% of my relationships.
I spent the last fucking week of my own fucking house on eggshells.
We'll back in a good place.
But it's just constantly,
you know,
th th th emotional abuse,
I mean,
women have the fucking market cornered on that.
This is,
this is a different podcast.
So anyways,
that's a different topic.
So you're,
you're,
uh,
um,
instructional videos on how you put it out.
First of all,
you know,
you're,
you're already ahead of 90% of people.
Just by the way it looks,
the quality of the way it's shot because so much of it is just somebody,
you know,
literally wearing a Gopro,
staring into a mirror while they played drums that you supposed to try to
fucking learn something out of that.
That's,
well,
that's exactly why I made this thing.
I mean,
I've been teaching for like 20 years and I work with,
you know,
a lot of pros,
a lot of my contemporaries,
a lot of big name dudes who are out in the real world touring with big bands.
Um,
in addition to me touring and recording and,
um,
I never,
you know,
I always wanted to do an instructional thing,
but with the way technology's evolved with Instagram and youtube and everything,
like everyone's a quote unquote teacher now.
Yeah.
So,
um,
by the way,
there's,
so there's this inside thing that I always see something,
I think it's fucking amazing,
a drum thing and then I send it to you and you just like,
eh.
You know what that reminds me of is when,
you know,
it's when people come up to me and then they just pick like some,
somebody super popular at the moment,
like what do you think is so and so that person is really funny,
honey.
You got to be like,
yeah,
I mean they're up there.
They're,
yeah,
they're on stage doing things.
Yeah.
They're saying things that people are really reacting with.
Laughter.
You just have to say straight up facts.
Yeah.
I know what I do.
I just like,
I would never take down another comment publicly,
but on the phone with my friends or which is we fucking eviscerate so many
people and then eventually it comes around to us and then we just start trashing
each other and just laughing our ass off.
And then the end,
everyone we trashed,
we just go,
Hey God bless them.
Bless them.
They're out there.
That's what it's all about.
I do that same shit too.
I have text threads with friends of mine where we do with the same same thing
and were just as brutal and work to each other and towards cells.
Yet how many jokes,
like back in the day when I was working the comedy cellar in New York,
how many jokes I lost,
how many shirts I could never wear again and all of this cause we sit,
just sit there and like the guys used to go down and they would watch you on
stage and they would be staring at you with like,
it would be Patrice breast is soul.
Oh Man.
A Foss Norton.
And they would just stand in there in the doorway.
We could see none of the crowd could see him and you had to like totally commit
to your fucking act.
Wow.
And uh,
I remember Kevin Harmony first fucking came down and he's like 20 years old and
they were doing that to him.
And I remember he didn't get rattled.
He did a little bit and then the first time and then he didn't have to,
once he didn't get rattled.
And I remember thinking like,
wow man,
this kid is a,
he's got the force.
Wow.
Yeah.
Because I was sitting there,
those guys were all my contemporaries.
Sure.
We would like 10,
15 years older than Kevin [inaudible] and these guys are my contemporaries and I
could find,
I was like,
Oh God,
they're going to stare at me.
And then you almost felt like he deliberately had to say something to bomb or
some shit like that.
So I don't know.
Do you guys ever do stuff like,
uh,
do you ever watch to go out and see,
see if like for a comedian to watch a,
uh,
a friend of yours bomb?
If not,
if it's like,
if the set means something,
but they just stopped it and they try a joke and they just eat shit.
It's one of the funniest things ever do.
Like when you watch a friend of yours play drums that go for a fill or
something,
if they eat shit on it.
Yeah,
it's totally different.
Just just by the nature of what you're doing.
So much of it is just throwing shit against the wall and seeing what sticks.
And just being like,
Hey,
I fucking try it like that.
I love Comedians and I respect Canadians so much because,
you know,
I'll go around town and see you or other girls just go out one night and go to
the comedy store or something and someone will walk up on stage with a slip.
I've seen you do this and a bunch of other people like,
oh yeah,
just like,
Oh,
I'm just working some shit out.
Oh yeah.
You know,
like subjects like Ah,
that didn't fucking work.
You know,
and,
and like that,
you can't do that with music.
Like people are there to see a show and it something,
it's like you want to,
what about,
what about the,
uh,
the jam section?
Isn't that what you guys call it?
When you look at each other then you just wait and like there are,
there are like this,
there aren't a different musical situations.
There's some bands go out and like we're planning exactly like the record.
Sure.
And then there's other people,
like if we play it like the record one more time,
I'm going to blow my brains out.
Can we?
Absolutely.
And there's certain something else,
there's situations where you can jam and improvise and uh,
you know,
like I would do that
with the Mars Volta or like,
or like anti master be certain sections where we just go away out into outer
space for half an hour.
What was that like when,
when you got that Gig and,
and you had to follow it was crazy.
All of those amazing drummers that were in the band,
all the shit that they came up with engine,
you have some except ridiculously,
uh,
a short amount of time to have to learn it and all that.
Um,
basically,
uh,
I got the call to do it and um,
and Juan,
the bass player who,
who used to play bass in racer x,
by the way,
for the last I heard of the band.
I don't know who they are.
Okay.
I'm sure I'll fuck up their name on the next podcast.
We'll talk about eighties and SPANDEX and feathered hair.
They're pretty deep into that scene.
But yeah,
so [inaudible] one came over to my studio with a fellow based player.
This Guy Jonathan [inaudible],
really good buddy of mine.
Now.
And John came over just to watch me like so,
so Juan came over and like we plugged in my iPod and he's like,
do you know this song?
You know?
And I'm like,
I don't know.
I'd never played along to this stuff.
I just kind of like the first record.
So one's playing with me and John's just sitting there like two feet in front of
me just staring at me,
watching me like,
and then Jesus Christ.
Yeah,
I know it's stressful and a,
and I never played the music.
I was just like,
I kind of know this thing or you know,
just from being a fan of that crap.
Did you do before then?
Nothing.
It was like,
Hey,
I'm lying.
I'm in line at Starbucks when he called me and then I had to go to a recording
session all day and then I was like,
I can meet you after I'm done with this session at night.
And then he was like,
okay.
And like that,
you know what I mean?
How bad did you need that Mars Volta Gig at that point in your career?
Was that something like it was huge.
Yeah.
It really put me on the map.
I mean because of the lineage of dudes that were in that band and how like the
reputation that band has.
Um,
I mean I,
I'd done things before that,
but nothing of that level,
you know,
so,
um,
it was huge.
So I had about two weeks,
you know,
to learn the music and it was a two and a half hour set.
Uh,
you know.
Yeah.
And so what do you,
what did you do?
Shut it out.
Yeah.
Charted everything out.
Um,
how long does it take you to and when,
when like how true to the original thing John Theodosia.
Well,
yeah.
Well I'd love,
I'd love John's playing.
I think he's amazing and I think his parts are incredible.
I think that first record is really a masterpiece.
So I wanted to do everything that I could in the time that I had to play
everything.
Note for note,
cause I think that's really important with that.
It's like,
it's like what situation you're talking about earlier.
Like people go to see those songs off that first record and they want it exactly
right.
Like I would want to see that.
So I went out of my way to get everything totally note for note,
which you know,
was easier and more difficult in some certain circumstances.
But um,
there were other,
you know,
other songs where it wasn't really important as much.
Um,
so two and a half weeks to get it together and that and,
and like how,
how often will you jamming with the band?
I didn't meet the band until I got to Amsterdam and then we,
I mean me and Omar,
the guitar player in one,
like got the three of us jammed a little bit.
Uh,
I went down to Mexico and the three of us played through the arrangements and it
was like,
he was like,
yeah,
this is,
Omar was like,
this is fine.
Like you're fine.
But then I went to Amsterdam.
How much of a relief was it to hear that?
Well,
we,
we rehearsed everything without vocals,
which is difficult cause I use vocals to like sort of know where I am in the
song a lot.
Oh yeah,
I've made that mistake.
I've done that.
So he was like,
dude,
you want to,
you know,
you don't even need to be here.
This is fine.
It's all good.
And I was like,
okay great,
but you're still like freaking out,
you know.
So,
uh,
I get to Amsterdam,
meet the rest of the band,
then we run through the set.
And this is kind of funny cause I,
I wrote out all my charts and I put an extra floor,
Tom on my left and like a crash cymbal on my left,
like to the left of the high hat and I just put my charts on the floor,
Tom,
like hoping like no one would see,
you know.
Right.
And I get up halfway through and to go to the bathroom and I came back,
it was all calling.
Oh somebody took it.
Yeah.
And I like look over it one,
he like,
dude,
you don't need that shit.
You're good.
And I was like,
okay.
And then everything was fine.
We ran through the ran to the two and a half hours because there's a lot of
visual cues I was going to sink.
But if,
if they like that,
yeah.
If they,
if you went there and they weren't,
well during the first rehearsal wanting it,
note for note,
that must have been something a little bit easier where it's like,
okay,
these guys aren't going to be like Nazis about this and this.
This can be room for me to kind of,
yeah.
Pulled based on the situation based on sort of where they were coming.
The situation they were coming out of there were so like exhausted.
Um,
so they were just like,
you know,
this is,
this sounds like they were basically like,
we sound like a band again.
This sounds like a record.
Oh,
cool.
Which is great
because I did that first gig.
Yeah.
What was the,
uh,
that was,
um,
it was in Oslo.
Um,
I love that though,
that those people are great comedy fence.
Oh my God.
I have some of my fucking lunatic.
Some of my all time best friends are from are from Oslo.
So many of them.
Uh,
and so many amazing musicians from there.
It's insane.
My first really good show I ever had in Europe was in Oslo.
Really?
I don't know if it was them or I just finally was just like,
just cause I was too much in my head.
[inaudible] and other places like I'm in a different country.
Are they going to get this right?
I'm talking about shirts.
Do they have shirts?
Yes they do.
They are wearing shirts.
Oh Shit.
My timing is completely up and I was so fucking fed up with mediocre sets.
I think that when I was in Oslo I just didn't give a fuck.
And then they were also like picked up on it.
No,
they will kind of maniacs where they would like drinking and shit.
Just like,
ah,
these are the kinds of people I hang out.
And then it just Kinda,
I felt comfortable and uh,
and then the rest of the tour and then I went into Stockholm and I'll let,
and just everything else I've just sort of fell into place.
It's like,
Oh,
just act like you're here,
which are in Oslo.
No,
no,
no.
Act like I'm in America.
Oh gotcha.
Cause then even if they don't get it,
you get to play the arrogant American and you're like,
oh you should know everything about my country.
And I showed no nothing about yours.
And they almost want you to say that cause you,
you feed into their stereotype of like,
yes they are self-involved cunts and we're better than they are and they love
it.
Um,
I jump around a lot.
No,
that's okay.
I get it.
It's not like I've never listened to this before.
Yeah.
It's a shit show.
So yes.
So that first show,
um,
yeah man,
I was insanely nervous.
Um,
but it went fine.
And then as soon as I was like halfway through the show,
I remember I was like,
yeah,
I'm feeling good luck.
I'm going to try and like put on a little bit of a show here.
Like visually.
Right.
Cause that's always very important to me.
Like there's nothing more boring than seeing someone just up there just like
looking like they're doing their taxes.
That's me.
That's how I look.
Not Anymore.
A little bit better,
Dude.
Holy Shit.
Oh,
we gotta talk about videotaping yourself while playing drums,
which you made me do.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
My self esteem has never been lower.
I've never looked worse doing anything ever.
Even my early standup tapes,
which I have on Vhs,
which I can't even watch.
I don't look as bad.
Yeah.
Word slouching.
You know,
like,
but you won't,
so you don't slide this,
you know,
you don't slouch when you,
when you walk around and when you,
when you do stand up,
it's when you sit down that you slapped.
Actually,
you know something.
What I,
my posture is my posture.
I've,
I've learned from my shoulder being fucked up.
Yeah.
Is,
um,
all my weight is on my knees and I've noticed a lot of people do this.
When they stand up,
they actually,
their,
their um,
their hips are forward and you're sort of leaning back like standing like this
and what you're actually supposed to do.
You like to stand up totally straight like this.
Okay.
I feel like I'm puffing my chest out acting like you want to fucking fight.
Yes.
Especially coming from where I grew up in such an angry crazy state is outside
of Boston.
Forget about Boston itself.
I was in the suburbs and that shit was fucking nuts.
Stand up straight and then your knees are just slightly bent and your arms are
just hanging down and your shoulders are a little,
you know,
uh,
feel like they're back.
But they're not that just blind.
This is what I have to like learn how to do.
But there's,
this is exactly what I've said to you and what I say to everyone,
especially all these big,
big name working pros is it's like if you're slouching,
that's your sort of normal goto setting and you think that that's you sitting up
straight.
Right?
So that when you sit up straight or stand up straight,
it feels like you're puffing your chest out.
Cause I thought cognitive disconnect.
So you have to rewire everything.
So it's much more accurate.
So that's,
that's the thing,
when I work on all this technique,
body mechanics stuff with people,
like that's why I tell them to videotape themselves because you can't tell what
you actually look like.
It's brutal.
It's brutal for everyone.
It's brutal for everyone,
including me.
It's never,
it never gets easier.
So when something,
I started to talk about it.
So when you were,
you started playing drums and everything,
I imagine you just sat down and grabbed the sticks the way any other kid would
have.
Like when did you start to break down what you were doing?
Did you get hurt or did you just see a video of some guy where he made it look
effortless?
Good question.
Uh,
I think when I started getting really serious when I was like 14 or 15,
it was a matter of me just constantly going,
how lazy can I possibly be?
Like how can I play all this stuff I want to play and just be is like,
how,
like how,
how can I continually just make this easier on myself?
Like why would I do this if I could just do that instead?
Why do you think he thought that?
I don't know.
Uh,
maybe I'm just lazy.
No,
I was going to say that,
but you're not,
you're,
you're a driven guy.
Sure.
I think I've just became obsessed with like efficiency.
Um,
not like for the sake of it in and of itself,
but to be like I can play in more or say more or do more of the more efficient I
am,
there's more I can do.
It's more I can say the more you can emote that way.
Maybe it comes from,
you know,
my dad collects cars.
Maybe it comes from growing up in that culture of like talking about,
you know,
how you know,
a difference between like a Hemi and a wedge.
Right.
You know,
like the difference having dual spark plugs versus single,
like,
I don't know.
I mean maybe it all sort of mashed up together.
Um,
I,
I think it just,
you know,
I wanted to play everything and I realized from a young age,
probably subconsciously like I need to be as efficient as possible so I'm not
getting in my own way so I can play this stuff.
I want to play.
You know,
it's like the first time you heard becoming,
you know the Penn terra song,
first time I heard it I had to put it on a cassette tape and put it in a
handheld recorder and slow the speed down.
Right.
I remember standing in my mom's kitchen putting it up to my up to my ear,
slowing the speed done going,
what the fuck is going on right now?
Like having no clue how he could possibly do that physically and then just
sitting there and breaking it down and going.
Well that wouldn't be,
I still feel a lot of that way about a lot of this stuff.
Which by the way,
man,
you gotta give a shout out to Vinny.
Oh Lord man.
I was literally talking about texting with you.
Yup.
Cause talking on the phone.
Yeah.
And I was just going like why is this guy so fucking good in,
in like two hours later you sent me the texts that he had passed away.
Man,
it's fucking brutal,
man.
I was really bad.
I haven't been that bummed out in [inaudible] or I haven't been affected that
much by someone's death.
Like who?
I,
I didn't really know him.
I met him once,
you know?
Right.
But I mean he was a real hero of mine and,
and to a lot of people and he just had such a commitment to a very specific
aesthetic.
Like he's like,
this is the sound,
this is the feel,
this is the vibe.
And like I'm 100% committed.
Like,
and the fact that they were doing,
when all the shit that I was talking about that I was listening to that's just
face planted and then all this grunge came out and they will just like,
Nah,
we're going to keep doing this.
That's the great southern Trenco that's the records about is them being like
fuck all these trends.
Like fuck this grunge shit.
Like we're going to stay true to our metal roots.
He just keep doing this,
you know,
and like all that on that live record,
that live hundred and one proof record,
like I love that dude.
Fill in some holes in between songs.
Banter is incredible.
Larry.
There's fall,
you spoke with [inaudible] show recording.
Paul could show number one Faulconer Obama.
No bullshit.
I always love it.
That's pretty good fucking logging American hog antler.
Do strops,
Meryl Streep.
It's just like all this shit that if you set it now you'd be my favorite thing,
and I always talk about on this is when he,
when uh,
when Vinny counts off unbroken,
it's like in the middle of Phil talking like why are stronger than a notch
called arm broken?
I'm avenue in the icts,
we're having a good child and Diane,
Diane is already playing and it was just like,
did they do that?
Cause that was fucking cool.
Always Vinnie.
Like,
Oh God,
shut up.
I want to drink.
I think it was part of it.
Yeah.
I think he was probably just like,
fucking,
here we go.
You know,
like I love that.
That's such a great moment in that record because you can tell they're just
fucking having fun dude.
And that's why that shit,
that's part of the reason why that shit,
I never went to go see them because I heard the music and I had an idea in my
head what the crowd was going to be like.
I'm going to get the shit kicked out of me at this thing.
But that's one of the funny things.
I was just talking to a buddy of mine,
Jamie,
who I've been giving Skype lessons to in London every week for years and he was
telling me he went to see the Bronx,
the other,
the recently,
it's like,
you know,
pretty heavy like punk rock band and he said like,
he brought his wife and she was like,
they left.
They had a great time at the show and like everyone,
you know,
someone falls down in the pit,
someone picks him up.
Like everyone's looking out for each other and he said like they left the show
and his wife was like,
or he said,
I forget.
They were like,
we felt more unsafe walking the streets.
Then you did it at the show,
like with all these dudes beating the shit out of each other.
Yeah.
It just sounded like when I listened to the music,
there's a bunch of guys that were mad at their dad.
We're going to show up and then they were going to take the childhood out on me.
I just,
you know,
and I had fucking orange hair and it was just like,
I just didn't think it was going to end well.
So it's just like,
but that is one of my big regrets that I didn't,
there was a number of those bands that I didn't go out and go see because I was
just like,
dude,
I love this music,
but I'm going to go,
I'm going to get the fucking shit kicked out of me.
And you know,
I was also in my fucking,
my stupid single bass drum.
Barnum didn't need a double pedal.
The music didn't require it.
Bill,
I don't care.
He could do both.
One foot did this guy just saying all this shit that other people,
I just completely ignoring the,
this entirely new,
uh,
type of drumming in,
in all of these pioneers who were just,
there was like,
there was no roadmap on what to do when I was listening to all these other
fucking guys who were just saying shit that had already been said.
And like basically if you could have a foot is fastest bottom right then you
were bottom,
something like that.
I be this way,
my head was,
this is what I love doing when we're doing lessons together and just shooting
the shit or whatever is,
is,
is that massive amount of carry over between drumming and stand up comedy.
I mean,
it's,
Oh yeah,
it's huge.
And that's what's so fun about it.
Difference.
It's the exact same fucking thing of like,
you know,
uh,
the it guys,
the difference between a guy who changed comedy versus a guy who's just sort of,
you know,
doing comedy or if you just,
if you're on stage,
like just reciting your act versus being up there and having an idea and the
crowd reacts one way which actually affects how the show goes and everything.
And um,
I used to be so envious of musicians that could just sit down and play what they
feel or react to what another musician did and I just did not have that ability.
So,
uh,
when I got into stand up,
I remember like stand up.
I had the same feeling you had when you got down,
when you set it at a kid.
When I first time I remember when I went to a,
it was my second show is at this place stitches comedy club,
which no longer exists.
And um,
I went in there for this open mic and I remember just walking into all of these
open makers up at the bar,
all in different levels.
And I just remembered feeling like,
like,
like for the first time,
like I was with a demographic of people that like,
I didn't know,
I was just like,
yeah,
these guys are the same kind of fucking weird that I am,
this,
these Weirdos feel normal to me.
And it was the first time when I went to stand up,
you know,
even though I obviously had to learn from all these people,
there was,
I,
I had like this feeling of,
I know I don't really know exactly where I'm going,
but I kind of know where I'm going.
Like I know that I,
I just have to do this a bunch of times and what I feel in me is,
is,
is like that this is the right thing is going to kind of come out.
And uh,
so when I am in the,
I'm trying to think,
one of the first guys I ever saw just wing a set.
I saw this guy,
Frank Santa Rally,
and he went up there and knowing what I know now about comedy,
I think it was because the host brought them up and they were playing this weird
music and she started doing this dumb dance and he did it with her and he had
this totally serious look on his face.
He was already killing before he even took the mic out of the mic stand.
But I think that little improv exercise opened him up and he just went up there
and it was like he was just fucking talking and,
and I had seen his act a bunch of times.
Sure.
And uh,
then I remember thinking like,
oh he should be,
you should do that again.
He should do it.
Like everything was so precious.
Got gotta hang on to every front of thing you ever said.
And it wasn't until like listen to the musicians were there,
that whole,
those types of bands where it's just like a yeah.
Just how the song came out that night.
That was the mood we were in.
Right.
And I remember trying,
like I tried to apply that.
Yeah.
Cause it's the exact same thing I have.
People say to me real hard at what you do cause you wake up,
you go,
you're a baby mama.
Dot.
You're already playing.
You're already talking.
I'm just talking into a microphone.
I have to learn how to speak.
Yeah,
but use through sounds.
but put an instrument,
but you being able to stand up and wing a set.
You have to be just funny,
inherently funny.
Obviously it takes work,
but you have to be a funny person to be able to do that as opposed to someone
who has,
all you do is when it,
if it doesn't work,
you just make fun of yourself.
It's the,
it's the,
it's like literally,
you know,
if he can't dance,
you just learn a little two step and let the woman do all the fucking work and
seen it's over.
It's the same fucking thing.
You go up there,
you wing an idea.
If it doesn't either just make fun of yourself or you blame the crowd.
Yeah.
But that's like saying like,
Oh yeah,
when I go to do a drum solo,
it's like,
yeah,
just kind of played the Tom's a little bit and then the symbol.
No it isn't.
That's what I'm saying.
It isn't.
Yeah.
So I'm saying the same thing to you or not.
It's not that easy.
Like,
I mean,
but that,
you know,
I have uh,
dudes who I teach who are like mainly Torin guys I've played with like pop acts
or whatever and they're like,
I can sit down and play the shit out of a show,
like from start to finish nail everything.
But if I sit down and someone's like,
Hey,
play a little bit like I don't know what the fuck to do.
Like I can't just play by myself.
And that's the same also type of a thing.
Someone has a routine or bits of show put together,
they could kill it.
But then if they just walk up and
Oh,
somebody heckles him and fucks up the APP,
I guess that's exactly right.
Same in music and comedy.
Someone throws a fucking beer bottle at you or whatever.
Yeah.
People throw shit at you guys.
That does not have,
I mean I've had shit thrown at me,
but like I usually to served as [inaudible] you guys would just be up there
singing and for some reason somebody just wants to throw a bottle.
I don't know.
I,
and a lot of times it's like the band is like the crowd is enjoying the show.
It's like they just want to connect with you less.
I hit him with the bottle,
like the plastic water bottle I was drinking and my fingerprints were on it and
it touched him.
So yeah.
And then he yelled at me.
It was epic
and people are crazy.
What um,
what's the most fucked up thing that you ever saw in a show?
Cause you're the drama,
you get to see the,
have you ever said your lead singer go to crowd surf and just sort of disappear
in the crowd and the people can't find them and you guys are looking at each
other like how are we going to end this song?
You know,
one of the most brutal things I ever saw,
it was,
I wasn't involved.
I was just a spectator,
but,
um,
I was seeing,
I think it was some,
it was some Mike Patton band.
He was,
he looked Melvin's or Fanta moss or he's in that dead cross now,
right?
Yeah,
I got to see them.
Bartow.
Yeah.
Um,
I can't remember who it was.
anyway,
they brought up like,
uh,
jelaby off road to like sing a song and he went to go like,
this is maybe five,
10 years ago.
And he went to go like state like stage dive or whatever.
And his first step he took,
he said that on some girl's face.
Oh No.
Then just ate shit.
Slide like family guy fall.
How it's like one frame and then your arms are behind your back
shit.
And it was,
I know it just like took him like 10 minutes to get back on stage and it was
just like,
oh,
and what is the band doing?
Were they just playing,
kept playing and you know,
it was just like,
oh God.
Brutal.
So what do you do?
Does the guitar player play a Solo?
Like how do you eat?
I mean,
I think they just kept,
you know,
patent was up there.
I think they just kept like going,
you know,
and he eventually made his way back on stage or whatever,
but it was just like Bam.
It was just like,
oh,
oh yeah.
Um,
I mean maybe like for me playing,
there's a drum cam video on,
on,
on Youtube I think is the first thing you saw of me.
The,
the volt,
the Goliath.
Oh yeah.
And I didn't understand your technique.
I'm like,
this guy's fucking arms are going to fall off.
Yeah,
yeah.
Cause I was going ape shit and go nuts and hitting super hard and um,
or it looks like it's hitting hard.
Um,
and one thing Cedric he used to love to do is he would just like take my crash
symbols away from me.
Like,
so there's a part in that video where he just takes my crash,
uh,
and only have two up.
So,
uh,
he takes my crash and then like,
you know,
like basically just jumps on it,
uh,
and like throws it up and down and then takes the symbol off and stomps on it.
And then takes the cymbal stand and throws it over my head and almost hit it,
takes out the camera.
And I'm like,
this is the,
this was the first time he'd ever done this.
So like,
did you know that he did shit?
Like,
no.
No.
I mean,
not really.
I don't think so.
Did you think it was because of your playing?
No,
he was just like rock and rock and roll,
you know,
like my fucking self esteem.
It'd be like,
he hates me,
I'm getting fired and then it'd be getting mad man.
Like,
do some fucking trash my shit.
Well,
I did get mad eventually.
Um,
uh,
and my company was like,
what the fuck?
Um,
but anyway,
yeah,
because he had to keep sending you shit.
They were like,
Shit,
what the fuck?
We send you symbols to play knock to get broken by the lead singer,
you know?
So,
uh,
so yeah,
this is the first time he ever did it.
So you can see me like turning around to my tech,
like,
Hey,
fucking give me another symbol on a stand.
Like,
come on dude,
like,
and a,
and he's like,
hold on a sec.
You know,
and then,
uh,
and then he was just like,
I gotta make sure and wait until he's actually done,
I don't know how far he's going to take this.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Wait until he's out of that mood.
Yeah.
And then he eventually,
you know,
eventually brought another one up and it was fine.
But like,
uh,
well not to get into the gossip,
we able to just kind of sit there and say,
hey buddy,
I love being in the band man,
but I need my simple,
see,
I mean I got to a certain point where I was like,
dude,
like really?
You know,
like come on,
cause he actually plays drums too.
I was like,
you know,
you know how much,
annoying that that would be right.
You know,
he's like,
Oh shit.
Yeah,
you're right.
Sorry man.
Just get carried away.
You know,
I used to,
when I was e five,
eight if I ever saw that on TV or if I was in the crowd or whatever when I was a
kid and I was playing drums and everything,
I used to just be a tech to just give it to me.
Right,
right.
I need a symbol.
Right.
Totally.
Can you just sit there and just break it in front of me?
It's like I would've loved to have had that.
Yup.
Like when I ever watched like the WHO or whatever.
Yeah.
And you know,
it's funny cause I don't know if they just had like some piece of shit,
you know,
the Japanese version of the lesser or whatever.
Or if it was an actual one.
It now like all those vintage instruments,
how much they're worth.
Like I,
Pete Townsend and his probably,
you know,
oh my God,
probably seven figures and guitars
at least.
Yeah.
My Buddy,
my buddy Jerry plays with Dick Dale,
you know,
and uh,
he brings out this like,
I don't know what it is if it's like an explorer or Les Paul or something,
but it's like from the 50s and his amp is also from the 50s and it's like that
shit's worth several hundred thousand dollars and he tours with it
crazy.
Well,
yeah.
And he's the guy who plays her frog,
but he plays like,
Oh,
right hand guitar left the upside down.
It doesn't change the strings.
That sounds right to me.
Yeah.
He does something super fucked up and weird.
That's all that,
that pulp fiction song.
Yep.
That's it.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well where can people get this video?
And you have mentioned that they can go to my website,
[inaudible] dot com spell your name.
We're done.
We're done over here.
L I,
t c h,
Dave [inaudible] dot com.
And uh,
you can just click on instructional course,
it'll pop up there and you can get everything there.
It's just streaming and uh,
you know,
everybody does these sort of subscription based courses now and then they just
take your money forever and I didn't want to do that.
So I'm like,
you know,
you just pay for it once you stream it forever,
as long as you want.
I'm not going to charge your credit card for seven years and you know,
like,
I don't want to do that.
So,
uh,
I've had a couple of those and then you forget you have exactly day somebody is
looking at your stuff going like,
dude,
what the fuck is this?
Did he ever tell you I had,
I had a cell phone number for like 15 years that I never use.
Are you serious?
Yeah.
Like I was bitching to my wife going like,
is that mine?
Oh,
Siri,
no worries.
Um,
I was paying,
it just seemed like a ton of money.
All of a sudden for my cell phone.
It just kept going up and up and up.
I said,
I don't understand why I'm paying,
why am I paying so much more than fuck?
It was going to have to like fucking three,
400 bucks.
Right.
So she goes,
let me see it.
And she looked at it.
She goes,
all right,
first of all,
I think I had three cell phone numbers.
Why?
Yeah,
she's still going at me.
Yeah.
Like I like I got like fucking chicks on the side and I'm like,
no,
I don't know.
We looked it up.
Here's what it was back in the day.
Um,
when you were on the road,
you know,
in,
you'd bring it,
you fucking big thick laptop or whatever and all these hotel rooms were charging
anywhere from seven,
10,
$11 a day for the Internet.
Right.
So I,
I wouldn't,
I was working places Tuesday through Sunday,
so it was like six times,
you know,
10,
11 bucks.
It was like,
man with the taxes customer,
like $70 to be on the Internet.
So,
uh,
my buddy Robert Kelly,
right?
He's like,
dude,
what do you want to do again?
He knows all the fucking technology.
Cause did you get the fucking,
it's this was his hotspot,
right?
Things.
So it had its own number.
You plugged it in to your computer and blah,
blah blah.
Right.
So I tried to use it twice and it never worked.
Now says he's fucking things never fucking work.
And I knew in the back of my head it's like I gotta call these guys up and
cancel it or whatever.
And I just,
I just never did and I just forgot about it.
Oh.
And recently I actually found it,
I still have the thing.
So that was one of them.
I forget what the other one was,
but it was like two things that were of that.
One was like a fax machine number and the other one's like all this outdated
shit.
So she got,
she got that taken off and then I think one time when I left the country I
switched my plan and they didn't quite switch it back or something.
So now it's down to like a buck 80 a month.
It was your,
was your mobile hotspot like the size of this fridge?
No.
You know,
it was the size of a hockey puck.
I mean it was big,
was a big plastic thing.
And you just had a,
and you had to come up with all the stuff that trips me up,
you know,
you got to come up with a password and just like,
oh,
just a couple,
two,
three of those hoops that I have to jump through.
Oh yeah,
that's too much.
But I've been working on lately though.
Um,
I remember seeing,
maybe I was watching one of the interviews you did or whatever you said,
how you think everyone should have a therapist.
If you just talk to somebody.
Yes.
The world be a better place.
Well,
um,
I haven't gone to therapy and like for,
I finally at one point I was just going like,
dude,
I'm always going to be fucked up.
I mean,
I can sit here like,
well,
I'm done talking about my childhood,
so I'm just going to be talking about the dumb shit that happens every day.
Like it was,
it was feel starting feeling a reality show or one on one reality show.
But,
um,
recently I've really been working on my not snapping over little things.
Uh,
and I,
I started to snap this morning for the first time in like four days and it
actually felt a little weird,
but,
um,
I,
I'm just gonna keep trying to do what I'm doing with it and I keep talking about
it allowed,
so I remember it because,
you know,
it's like,
Hey,
I'm going to go to the gym.
Yeah.
You know,
and then that week you fucking crush it.
Next week you three quarters of crush it,
a month later you're eating Oreos.
Sit on a couch.
So what do you,
so what are you doing?
Like,
do you just like breathe deeply years?
Like when you say Aye?
Well,
big thing is driving.
Sure.
So when I get in the fucking car,
I just say like,
uh,
first of all,
I leave enough fucking time to get there.
I don't leave the utopia time.
This should take a half hour.
Nope.
How dare these other people in front of me have other plans in other lives.
So I leave plenty of time and then I,
it's just weird.
I drive slow slower.
I'm probably driving somebody nuts by him.
I drive slower.
I stopped at yellow lights.
I let people go.
I chill out.
I actually,
uh,
is another thing.
I swear to God,
this is like,
they use this for premature ejaculation.
I'm actually using this.
I listened to baseball.
They stay,
think I'll think about baseball.
I never understood that it be,
if you don't want to fucking bust a nut,
I start thinking of fucking call your strobe ski now.
Fucking got a hard tech thinking about the fucking left field or the red sox and
it's just confusing.
It's like,
wait,
am I attracted to this guy?
Um,
I just didn't feel like you are present.
sorry,
I was busy.
I was thinking about fucking at Jerry Remy.
No,
I put on like a,
there's something about smoking a cigar and listening,
listening to baseball on the radio is like some old man shit and it slows life
down.
I don't know what it is.
So I,
uh,
I just have it on and they just have a wonderful day for a ball game,
man.
Just crazy.
The lineups,
blah,
blah.
You know,
he's just,
yeah,
he's extending his bratty of Aa.
And you just sort of drift along and I just,
and I just know and I just,
I don't have,
I hate saying this,
but you know that the people always say like,
you know,
you got to give up like expectations and shit.
First of all,
I also like googled how to stop snapping over the little things in.
The first thing I clicked on was this woman going,
did you ever,
have you ever blown to say everything that I've done?
It's like,
yes,
yes.
So she goes,
here's four techniques and I'm reading this shit and I am like five minutes into
reading this and before she says,
you know,
I've been doing this for like a week and I'm like,
what?
Literally started snapping.
Like you don't change in a week.
Okay,
this is,
this is going to take me.
I just turned 50 this will take,
if I work my ass off,
this will take all of my fifties
to not to not do.
That's why I was joking with a buddy of mine,
why one of the most real as characters ever in any movie was,
was private hooks in police academy member.
She's always all mousy.
That black girl hang and then the end she'd be like,
and I remember joking,
you know,
every movie she'd go back to being mousy again.
She had the exact same character arc.
And it's just like,
when is she,
you know,
in reality is,
is that's what it's like to try to change yourself as a person is you have,
you know,
fucking up fucking up fucking up for 90 minutes and then whatever or whatever,
how much time the move goes by in the movie and then you have that breakthrough
moment and you don't move dirt bag and then the next day you know you're going
to fall back again or maybe two days later or whatever.
So yeah,
but that,
that's the,
but when you,
you know,
if you continue to do that work on yourself where you fall back isn't as far
down the ladder as you were before.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah,
no,
I,
yeah,
believe me,
dude,
like I'm,
I am committed to this because it's going to make my relationship with my wife
so much better.
I'm telling you,
dude,
if I could just stop snapping at little shit,
she's got nothing.
She's got the real motivation.
She's got nothing.
No,
because what I'm still doing,
this is something else that I'm gonna I'm,
I'm starting to let go of is the way when you're in a relationship with a woman,
like thinking the way a guy thinks,
you think I'm going to do this and then it's gonna,
then it's,
then she's going to be happy with me and she'll be in a good mood and then I'll,
the egg shells go away.
Right.
And what you realize is that,
that that's yeah,
you're chasing a a,
that's like a Ponzi scheme.
Like there's,
there's no meaning having expectations for your actions is,
uh,
no,
I,
I just like,
I'm just always going to win.
Neuer inherently just because I'm a man and I'm not going to see things the way
she does because she's a woman.
And touching that and what she views as important versus what I view as,
or she views is not a big deal.
And I think is a big deal,
is not going to Mesh.
Not because she's a bad person or I'm a bad person,
it's just because we are wired differently.
And,
uh,
so I forget what something happened
just this morning and I started to get upset and I was just like,
well,
why would I think that she would blah,
blah,
and it just fucking went away.
That's great.
So I can,
but I'm afraid of this because now I'm filling and we just become this spineless
guy or oh hell,
you know,
sitting there holding her purse.
You know what?
I'll talk about the same shit I have with my,
with my therapist a bunch of times,
uh,
because coming,
not even necessarily talking about that specific thing as a human being,
but talking about that specific thing as being the source of your creativity in
some way.
Yeah.
You know what?
I mean like that's,
no,
there's there,
there is a thing with comedians with,
if I get happy I won't be fun anymore.
Which is what musicians too.
It's a huge myth because I'll tell you why.
What happens is,
is like once you get everything you want,
you know,
as far as like you found love and you have the kid and your kid comes home,
it's going.dot,
dot,
dot.
Big Smile students.
The fucking greatest,
greatest fucking thing ever.
It's one of the few things in the world that lives up to the hype,
right?
Other than downloading your fucking video,
boom,
Bam.
Cross promoting.
Um,
what,
Eh,
what replaces all your angsty Lolitas and I'm sleeping on a futon and shit isn't
this new fear of that you're now going to lose it.
All right?
Like what if something happens?
Like I can't tell you since having a kid,
like any new scenario like,
hey,
I'm going to go take her on the swing.
Like immediately this horror movie that Steven King could not fuck with or maybe
that maybe he has kids or something.
That's how he writes.
But like the shit that goes through your head about the possible stuff that
would happen.
And always in the end,
I'm either murdering a person or an animal.
One of the other dude,
I've actually had fantasies of jumping down on a cougars back in somehow.
I know that UFC move will you choke it out.
And I wrapped my legs around his belly so it can't claw me.
And I sit there while I'm eating his sandwich.
Thinking of all of this because my wife said that she's going to like just take
her out in the backyard,
um,
turns into a Joe Rogan episode.
Yeah.
So all of that and then like those fucking crazy thoughts,
we'll then we'll then fuel your,
um,
your act hopefully.
So,
um,
any as well.
I have to,
I've got to read a little bit of advertising.
Okay.
You want to see some comedy here?
Um,
once again,
my apologies to the Special Smith.
I feel so fucking bad about that.
And I told,
I told the singer I'd throw a couple of concent form and then I called his pant,
the smiths,
and then I had all these fucking mopey Morrissey people.
He left at band 30 years.
You'd go,
man,
they're never getting baked in other people freaking out.
Did they get back together?
Like I caused like this whole fucking thing.
I feel like such a,
by the way you're,
you're,
you need to fill him like a video of your Morrissey dance.
Oh,
the Morrissey dance.
Oh yeah.
Have you done that yet?
No,
I got to get it down better.
It's one of my favorite things I've ever seen.
I don't dislike Morrissey.
I just,
I like irritating people that are really into shit.
Like star wars fans.
Oh,
I saw them.
I saw one of the,
I saw one of the new newest star wars ones.
It was fucking great.
It was actually really good.
Now that it's not like a muppet movie,
like it was too,
like it was like,
it was like muppets with space and then some bad self help.
You know,
this guy's good.
He's in the Lee.
His light sabers Blue Dude.
I think star wars is great,
but when people like make their lives revolve around it,
I just,
it's like there's so much other shit out there in the world.
That's why people don't like baby boomers because baby boomers like,
they just make so much about what they grew up in and fucking all the stuff they
did.
If they just fucking just did what they did and just shut the fuck up about it
and let them other generations realize how cool they were,
they would have been fine.
Um,
all right.
I gotta read a couple of these things here.
All right.
Okay.
Bill stitch fix sent you close while you were in Paris.
They're actually really normal and wearable and much better than the other
clothing companies we've had.
I probably shouldn't read that out loud.
All right.
This is going to be,
I guess these guys make really normal wearable clothes.
Okay.
Did you hear that?
That was the sound of money going out the door stitch fix everybody a
convenience stitch fix understands that Louie lot much fucking copy.
This is,
this is like,
that's a novel stitch fix understands that life gets busy.
So tell,
tell them your sizes and your favorite type of clothes and how you want to spend
and your personal stylist will pick out clothing for you based on your
preferences.
Try before buying.
If an item doesn't fit or you don't like it,
no worries.
Just send it back free of charge.
No clue what you did in those clothes.
They must have a giant washing machine that is just goes in.
Some guy in a hazmat suits shows up style.
Some of us have it,
some of us don't.
But just because a sense of style seems elusive for some doesn't mean it's
impossible to obtain.
A,
there's no time like the present to discovered the style you never knew you had
with somebody else's talent.
And you can with a little help from our friends at stitch fix that it's not
somebody else's talent.
This is reminding me of every bad eighties movie where they do like a makeover
on you.
Um,
stitch fix has reinvented how we find and buy clothes.
Just answer some basic questions about you sizes.
Favorite styles and budget right from your laptop,
smartphone or tablet,
your personal stylist and springs into action hand selecting five brand new
clothes.
Ironing for you.
I know,
I know.
Personal stylist sounds like something only the rich and famous can afford,
but you can't to a stitch fix styling fee is only $20,
which is applied as a credit toward anything you keep and sense.
Your personal stylist uses only your preferences to pick your clothes.
You're still in complete control.
Once your item arrived,
try them on and only pay what you want to keep.
Don't like something needed,
normal size.
Just send the items back.
This is why I don't think I'm supposed to read all of this because they just
keep repeating the same shit.
No questions asked and the shipping is always free.
Both ways.
Get your fix whatever you want or sign up to receive scheduled shipments.
The choice is yours.
Um,
I love stitch Fitch.
Fix.
Dave.
I didn't realize that.
I guess I do because they have normal wearable clothes.
I'm sure these are great.
I'm sure these are great and I know you will to call the action.
Hurry to stitch Fitch stitch
fix.com/bird he gets started now.
Keep all five items in your box and you'll get 25 25% off your entire purchase.
That stitch fix.com/burr a stitch fix.com/bar hey,
what do you think's going to happen?
All the strip malls and malls in the future.
Like what are we going to do with those?
Because this is going to be no stores like,
cause everybody's shopping from the Internet online.
Yeah.
Even like they'll buy like a vintage guitar without even fucking trying to know
me.
Um,
and have it show up and realize that it isn't in the guys in Japan.
There's nothing you can do about it.
He's got your money.
I remember I bought that,
you know that prince album that,
that really,
uh,
the one quest love always talks about where it was just like it was,
I think it was just an all black album.
It's,
it's not available.
Like he put it out and Oh,
I don't know.
Yeah,
I bought it off some guy in Japan.
I didn't know what showed up.
It was like the fucking soundtrack to chips and what am I going to do?
Call it paypal.
They're gonna find him.
Hey Man,
we're a web country in the United States and unless you returned that fucking
money for that record,
we will.
We will do absolutely nothing because you'll just change your name and become
somebody else.
All right,
policy genius.
If you have a car,
you have insurance,
you have car insurance,
we should at least if you have a home,
you should.
You have home insurance.
If you're alive,
shinny on life insurance,
four out of 10 people don't have life insurance at all and it's not their fault.
It's life insurance.
Salt shopping for life insurance is confusing and it takes forever.
Hey,
insurance company,
don't totally blame yourself.
A lot of guys can't deal with their own fucking mortality or they live alone and
who gives a shit if they diary?
So policy genius made it easy.
Policy Genius is the easy,
easy way to compare life insurance online.
In just five minutes.
You can compare quotes from the top insurance to find the best policy for you.
And when you compare quotes,
you saved money.
It's that simple.
In fact,
policy genius has helped over 4 million people shop for insurance and placed
over $20 billion in coverage,
and they don't just make life insurance easy.
They also compare disability insurance,
renter's insurance,
health insurance,
one stop insurance.
Stop here.
If you care about it,
then they cover it.
A,
if you've been putting off life insurance,
don't put it off any longer.
It's never been easier to buy in rates already.
20 year,
low policy,
genius.com the easy way to buy life.
Compare and buy life insurance.
I'll tell you one of the best things I ever did,
it was getting life insurance.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
I have it too.
It's like the,
isn't there like a relief.
My uncle works for farmers and he was like,
Dude,
you've got to get it.
Like,
let me hook it up.
And it was super cheap or easy.
Yeah.
When you're young.
Yeah,
I didn't when I was old they were like,
how old are you?
He smoked cigars occasionally.
Yeah.
We'll give you the old guy.
Occasional fee.
Here's supposed to say no,
no,
I know.
But now what they do,
they literally,
they fucking,
they take your blood now,
right?
I know.
And they,
yeah,
you so you can lie all you want.
They're going to find out what you're doing
speaking.
I say admit to bullshit the doing so they don't take your blood and figured out
what you're actually doing or they're like,
oh,
it's not that bad considering all this other shit and you've been here,
whatever.
But I just liked the fact that when I die that everybody's going to be taken
care of.
And this not going to be like,
you know,
I've had buddies of mine die unexpectedly,
my age,
it's unexpected and write your fares are not in order.
And then it's the double whammy.
Yup.
Where you know,
it's the,
you're no longer there.
And then people are like,
how the fuck are we gonna live?
Yup.
How are we going to pay the rent and take care of everything?
And that's sad.
But you know what isn't said is that joy of your new drum video.
I see.
I got out of that.
That was perfect,
dude.
I'm so happy for you because for the longest time I've been telling you with
your skills to utilize the internet,
get out there,
especially because you got something to say and all that.
And uh,
I am thrilled for you and I hope this podcast can help blow up the video because
you are the fucking man because,
uh,
I sucked at drums and I'm a comedian.
I've actually had people come up to me and say,
you know,
I've gotten to the point where people come up to me that wasn't that bad.
And before,
yeah,
it was bad.
It was definitely a dude.
That video where you were at Dean's birthday was fucking crushing.
Uh,
oh my God.
Dude,
that was so much fun.
Yeah.
But,
but yeah,
I just the fuck out of everything.
That's what it's all about,
man.
You know?
Oh yeah,
that was a,
yeah.
I gotta be honest with you.
Like those,
those fucking,
all of those things.
When Krishna hooked me up and got the jams.
Yeah.
Couple of those guys.
Uh,
no,
that was rice stuff and slack.
I mean just like,
um,
those things are the biggest of anything I've ever done in this business.
Um,
those are the biggest that was,
had been played with fucking Nikki Sixx.
Yeah.
Dude,
it's fucking ridiculous.
Yeah.
That's incredible.
Yeah,
because I really didn't earn it.
That's what I,
cause I always feel like with stand up as much as you know,
doing Letterman,
the HBO special duties like that,
it's like I did the hell gigs.
Like I fucking earned it and the cracker barrel at three in the morning and
Nebraska or whatever.
But there's these drum and gigs.
It's not like I had to audition.
It's just like,
oh,
that guy's funny.
I'll play a song with them.
Yeah.
I'm sick of the guys in my band.
Get up their freckles,
see what you can do.
Um,
all right.
That's the Thursday afternoon podcast.
Very special guests.
David Lynch,
thank you so much for coming on.
Finally get you on.
And thank you for all the,
uh,
all the,
all the help you've given me over the years.
Dude,
it's been my pleasure.
I've learned so much myself,
dude.
And one more thing.
Yeah,
I can imagine you had a fucking student more difficult than make the fucking
teach.
Oh,
I definitely have believed that.
Right?
I don't say any of that.
Um,
but uh,
uh,
for everyone who's listening to this,
if you want to go check out the course,
you can go to my website and during checkout,
if you type in Berber,
B,
u,
R,
you'll get 10% off of everything.
Get look at that is it gave him,
did not embrace the Internet.
Now you're fucking,
you're doing it better than I am.
I love it.
All right.
That's the podcast.
Enjoy the music and then we'll have a little,
a throwback Thursday afternoon podcast.
Have a great weekend.
Your cuts and I'll see you on Monday.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] what's going on?
It's,
it's the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
June 28th,
2010 right off the bat.
You should be thinking,
you know what,
Bill,
there's something weird with your voice.
Why does it sound like you're whispering?
Because I am fucking whispering in fucking Douche bag.
Why don't you go with your gut?
You know,
didn't you fucking brain?
Just tell you that I was whispering.
Did your parents beat you down mentally that bad?
That you literally question what that fucking voice in in Saudi.
Who was even saying?
That's the voice that makes you fucking when you go on a hike and if that little
voice in years go on.
Is there a mountain line staring at me?
Yes,
there is run.
All right.
Um,
I am whispering because I'm doing this fucking thing at eight 20 in the morning,
my girlfriend is sleeping in the other room.
I taped this fucking thing last night,
but for some reason I screwed up
and it didn't record 50 minutes.
I fucking did it.
I was going to upload it at midnight just like last week.
Okay.
And just like last week,
I am once again,
I'm Douche bag of the week back to back.
Just like the Lakers.
I'm a Douche bag two years in a fucking row,
uh,
two weeks in a row,
I should say our two times in a row,
whatever.
You know the analogy I'm trying to
let you guys know that I'm a fucking idiot when it comes to this.
The past two weeks and kind of try and trashed the Lakers anyways,
but they don't give a fuck.
They got their rings right.
You know what a wonderful organization.
They actually had to switch their parade route because they're stupid.
Fans were writing so much bunch of fucking animals.
All right,
Billy.
Ever going to let the Lakers Celtics series go?
You know what?
I don't think I'm gonna.
I'm reminded of it constantly.
Like I started watching World Cup soccer and watching all those fucking people
flopping around on the ground.
Anytime anybody kicked it back to their socks reminded me of watching Pau Gasol
play basketball.
The fucking flopping.
Fag.
All right,
let's not be this angry.
You can't be angry in whisper.
Ever seen that?
You'll see a couple fighting public.
They do that angry whispering.
That's not what I said.
You know damn well what the fuck's on right here?
He'll kill.
Shut the fuck up.
That's what I'm going to be doing.
So anyways,
um,
I actually did the podcast last night already and uh,
fighting through,
I was like sweating.
I was so god damn sick.
I did Vegas this weekend.
I performed at the Orleans casino.
Now few stand up nerds out there or if he fans of the podcast who listen every
week,
you,
you know that the Orleans casino was the last place George Carlin did a stand up
before he died.
So,
uh,
I went there and I asked them a ton of questions.
People who work there with totally cool.
Even one of the guys was actually telling me how Carolyn put together as hours
of material.
You know,
how he would come in and it would be like an hour and 20 minutes and before his
special he'd watch them whittle it down and by the end of the weekend it would
be like an hour,
right on the nose.
Gave me chills listening to it,
and also made me really feel like,
uh,
I need to start working harder as a fucking comedian.
And,
uh,
someone,
they're also gave me a,
a ticket stub from his last show was fucking awesome.
But I,
uh,
made the mistake.
I,
um,
the Orleans Orleans casino is actually off the strip.
It's kind of cool.
So my hotel room at a view of the entire Strip and,
uh,
I would have been content to just stay out there at the Orleans casino because I
liked it.
I liked the vibe of the crowd was a little bit older as am I,
you know,
so there wasn't a lot of craziness going on.
It was just straight up,
let's booze,
let's eat,
let's gamble.
You know,
it wasn't a bunch of people fucking,
you know,
in Alica Gaggle of chicks screaming at the sunroof of a fucking limb out,
we got a limo,
beaches,
you know,
everybody tags everything with bitch nowadays.
Is that from the Rick James Sketch?
I'm Rick James Bitch.
Then everything became bitch,
whatever long fucking story.
You know what I'm doing right now,
I'm looking at my laptop and the screen saver just has all,
all the albums on my iTunes or all the albums that don't really fucking exist.
The covers to the digital signals that I downloaded.
I'm actually looking at one that says Elvis speaking of Las Vegas.
And I came out to,
uh,
to elvisy entire weekend.
I had to do it.
I came out to that song that's used to be cute and now I realized that it's
about stocking someone,
you know,
has that fucking song.
Go hide in the kitchen,
had in the hall.
Ain't gonna do you any good at all?
It goes one side,
something man.
The kisses dot a team allowed Hawes is good and tear us apart.
It's like really?
Elvis does.
Does the woman have any say in that?
I'm going to fuck on
Volvo Bubba.
Yes.
Stuck on you.
You would think that,
uh,
that with them,
it's a guy in love.
But if you really listen to the lyrics,
it isn't,
it's a guy who can't accept the fact that the relationship is over in her mind
and she wants to move on.
Eh,
you know,
hey,
he just
won't fucking leave her alone.
It keeps pressing his sweaty out of shape,
iconic stomach up against her as he kisses her.
I mean,
that's what I got out of it,
but it was a great song to come out to nonetheless.
So anyways,
you probably asking,
hey bill,
you whisper in [inaudible]
how did you get sick?
I don't really know,
but I know who I'm going to blame it on.
How about that?
I was fucking,
uh,
like I said,
I was content to stay off the Strip at the Orleans casino,
you know,
but I brought my girlfriend.
So you know what that means.
They want to do stuff.
Let's go to the strip.
I heard they had some stores.
They are students on the strip.
Let's go to this trip and go to the store and see where to go to the stores and
the Strip.
Hi Sweetie.
Sweetie.
Do you want to go to this stores on this trip?
No,
of course.
I don't know.
I,
why would I want to do that?
If I had something I needed to buy,
I would go,
but I don't,
I don't want to go.
Yeah,
but I fucking learned.
I've learned to get through the fucking relationship.
You got to say yes to some shit.
You don't want to fucking do.
So I go,
yeah,
yeah.
Let's go to the fucking stores on the Strip.
Right?
So we fucking go out there and uh,
you know,
we go into all these fucking stores.
I noticed those really high end stores.
When you go into them,
they only have like 40 pieces is they call them.
You know,
it's very,
it's not like when you go into old navy
a what's waist size area,
we've got a hundred of that,
you know,
we get a hundred every fucking size and their stack from the floor up to the
goddamn ceiling.
And we got that ladder.
I fucking slides right across the wall.
That's how much product we have in here.
And that's just the goddamn change.
And you know why?
Cause they're 30 bucks a whack,
but you go into those fucking high end places and it stops being jeans and
dresses.
It starts being called pieces
and all of a sudden there's like 28 things and there's a ton of space and
everybody in those stores,
it looks like Mike Myers and that fucking sketchy used to do you know where he
danced?
Like the fucking German guy who liked to get shit on sprocket or some shit of
came out where the fuck name Lewis,
he's dressed all in black and he put his hands on his hips and he only moved his
legs.
Can you guys hear that person that somebody giggling like a maniac downstairs
person moved out downstairs?
Not The old guy.
My apartment's over two different apartments.
It's a little fucking spread out.
So anyways,
we start going to those goddamn shops.
Long Story Short,
I got actually admit one Louis Vuitton when you go in there,
uh,
I really liked their luggage,
man.
That luggage is fucking insane.
Like it's handcrafted.
Said I lied that,
you know,
look at that handcrafted.
Yeah.
Some guy took a hammer and nails on the inside.
Look at that craftsman ship.
You know,
they have an old Louis Vuitton trunk from like the early 19 hundreds and it's
still functional.
You know why?
Because it was made by hand using great materials.
So I was like,
you know,
and I liked this shit.
I like,
it wasn't made by a machine.
It was made by a human being.
So I asked him the smallest fucking piece of luggage they had,
which I guess would be considered kind of like a jewelry box.
And I asked him how much it was and they were like a $4,000 and uh,
I did the Eddie Murphy and Beverly Hills Cop,
you know,
I just,
I just totally played it off like I could afford it as I guy.
That's great.
You know?
Okay,
now why don't you close up this handcrafted thing and put it back up on the
fucking shelf?
I was actually pissed afterwards
for grant.
They fucking look me right in the eye when they said four grant for Greg.
You look at the fucking floor when you throw a goddamn number out,
like that should be ashamed of yourself charging that much fucking money.
I don't understand.
Do you know how fucking rich you'd have to be to buy a $40,000 fucking jewelry
box?
Jesus Christ.
Most people did.
Jewelry isn't worth that much.
And then when the fuck do you take it?
That's the thing about buying really nice clothes and really nice stuff.
I got my legs crossed right now and I'm swinging my foot around.
The fuck is wrong with me.
She caught myself in a really a feminist moment.
Whatever I'm allowed on,
I,
um,
what,
what the fuck are you gonna do?
Like someone will like,
that's when you know you're rich.
When someone will mug you,
not for what's in your luggage,
they'll just mug you for your fucking luggage.
You know,
when I go to do a,
the David Letterman program,
I go,
always go out.
I buy a nice God damn suit.
I always lose money whenever I do that show.
But I'm not going out there looking like a bum.
And I love the suits and I love wearing them.
But the second you put them on your freaking out like,
oh my god Ha.
Anything you go to brush up against,
you freak out
because it's an expensive goddamn suit as opposed to when you shop at old navy
in the gap,
you know,
the Anti Pussy where that they sell.
I wouldn't give a shit if I was walking through a fucking pig sty.
I mean,
I freak on my God pigs shit.
Oh,
it's okay.
I'm wearing gap jeans.
I've never wore gap jeans.
I would never do that.
The other was a kid in my high school,
his nickname was the gap nerd and he d he had no idea people use,
no one said to his face because he was a bigger guy,
but he always wore a gap jeans.
And he wasn't even that big of a nerd.
Now he always tucked his shirts in cause it was the 80s and a,
yeah,
they called them the gap nerd
and that was the end of his pussy getting career.
He had no idea,
had no idea.
She has to do with this big six foot,
four inch fucking red quarter roid gap jeans,
big stupid tag on the back gap.
It's like,
don't you notice that everybody else has says Levi Strauss.
That's what you want to have on.
And then the couple of kids whose dads have mafioso connections,
there's actually actually have guests jeans,
you know,
which in my world was chick jeans back then.
Um,
anyways,
I'm getting off the fucking beaten track.
So anyways,
so we will look,
we're going through all these,
these high end fucking stores.
I went into the Tom Ford store,
some of the most beautiful suits have ever seen in my life.
Also some of the most expensive,
but you get caught up in it.
I was actually in there because Tom Ford,
his entire line is not just the line.
It's like a lifestyle and it's like that dull Secchia beer guy.
Stay thirsty.
My friends,
it's like Steve McQueen man's man.
They had a fucking run,
a cigar cutter cutter made out of like a fucking,
I was going to say a rhino horn.
It wasn't,
it was an ox horn and ox horn cigar cutter are the most manliest fucking things
I've ever seen and I'm actually thinking about buying it.
I'm holding this fucking ox horn.
You know,
they had a ram horn cigarette lighter.
I'm not even lying.
I'm not even joking.
I'm actually considering buying this fucking thing.
Fortunately,
I walked out of the store,
you know,
and like 10 minutes went by
and then I just kind of had like that little fucking gut check moment there or
whatever.
Kind of looking at myself like,
dude,
did you almost just by a fucking ox horn,
cigars cutter.
Did you really?
Almost too.
Did you,
did you get that fucking caught up in that bullshit as like,
yeah,
I did.
Couple of things kept snapping me back into reality.
Um,
I don't like my,
I don't like buying shit made out of animals unless it's a leather jacket.
It's just a stupid cow ate hamburgers anyways.
It'd be fucking hypocritical when it fucking cows already dead.
Why don't we go the native American route and use up this whole fucking cow?
You know?
But I don't eat ox.
Although I did go to a Mario Batali restaurant one time and I got an ox tail
fucking stew or something.
I can't even remember what the fellow was,
but it was delicious.
Yeah.
Uh,
but anyways,
this is just no fucking need.
Unless the ox was already dead and you're like,
well,
we might as well
soft.
It's fucking horns and turned it into a cigar cutter.
Anyway,
so we get out of that thing and speaking of fucking cows,
so I dunno,
my girls like,
let's go get something to eat.
And I said,
all right,
here's a fucking Mcdonald's right there.
And she's like,
do you want to eat there?
And Soda was looking down at the ground,
all sad,
you know,
just doing that classic female manipulation thing.
She knew I wanted to eat there.
I just said,
there's a Mcdonald's there.
And then why would she say,
do you want to eat there and look down at the ground?
This question is for all the young male listeners,
if my whispering podcast,
why would a female do that?
Do,
do,
do.
I'll tell you why.
Because she doesn't want,
if not only does she not want to fucking eat there,
she already has a place where she wants to eat.
She's already,
she's already had this place that she's wanting,
wanting to eat it for probably a month before you ever went to Vegas.
But she's not going to tell you about it because if she tells you about it,
they'd give you time to do research on it and find out how fucking expensive it
was.
So
[inaudible] she looks down at the ground.
So immediately,
despite the fact that I know all this about females,
I take the bait.
Why?
Where do you want to eat,
sweetheart?
I'm their fifth burger place at Mandalay Bay.
I heard it was really nice.
Do you ever watch top chef?
Uh,
only when you're watching it sweetheart.
I don't like that show.
Fucking show is annoying.
I hate when the shift starts screaming those people fucking foreign accent.
You call daddy fucking grilled cheese sandwich.
Get the fuck out of my kitchen.
Hey.
Hey,
you think I'm fucking afraid of you?
You fucking Dosha.
You got a fucking problem with my grilled cheese sandwich.
You come up like a fucking gentleman and you take me aside.
They'll fucking be screaming at me.
Why get these fucking knives in my hand?
Stick it right to your goddamn trachea.
What do you think about that?
Huh?
I'll give you a fucking blow hole right out the front of your fucking neck.
Get out of my goddamn face before I take you by your fucking hair and wash your
face into this pile of shrimp that I haven't taken the shells off.
So I'll give you a bunch of little razor cuts.
Sorry,
could you actually smother somebody there?
You know I used to work in a restaurant or I uh,
I work the mesquite grill.
I worked in a fancy restaurant called the sable cafe and Cary North Carolina.
Very short lived.
It was supposed to be five star dining yet they had me working on a mesquite
grill.
Glassed in with a big chef hat is all these fucking people will be looking at
me,
you know,
and I had to cook up all this shit and I was done,
burgers,
shrimp bro,
Shit's the chicken sandwiches,
whatever the fuck we will make in the swordfish specials.
And then I turned around,
there was a little window and I'd hand it to the fucking Metallica fan who I
worked with who had a stick his hair up in the hat.
But this pre pubescent fucking mustache,
even though he was 19,
that was a funny thing about that job is I'd be sitting there looking out at all
these quote on quote elegant people in Cary,
North Carolina.
And then I'd look through the little port hole where I would stick the food
through to give to the fucking drug addicts on the lie.
I remember who,
they had a guy back there who was on a work release program.
Like at night he was in jail,
but it during the day he cooked it,
this fucking restaurant,
this guy was a douchebag.
And one time we went,
we were on our way to going out of business.
So at one time I was literally the grill chef,
the busboy and a dishwasher.
Let's not even get involved in the amount of fucking health code violations that
they're involved in there.
Cause I was,
I did not have time to wash my fucking hands,
put it that way.
Um,
so one day we was slammed,
I'm in back going,
hey,
we need some more glasses.
You know,
because we were running low on glasses and the fucking Douche on the work
release program goes,
well,
why don't we wash some Aha,
a novel idea,
you know,
like he's fucking intelligent or something.
Uh,
a novel idea I have.
It was only because the guy was,
was in fucking prison that I didn't say anything to him.
He had that sort of credibility.
But looking back,
he was a fucking pussy.
God Damn Little Shit.
He wasn't even that tall.
And this is back in the day though,
when you weren't that tall and if you weren't that tall,
you weren't that tough.
You were tough for a little guy,
but you are still a little guy.
This is before Jujitsu made it to America.
There was no UFC,
you know,
remember the first fucking UFC and hoists,
Gracie kept fighting all those big guys and you think that he's about ready to
get punched in the chest and the fuck had face or whatever.
And then all of a sudden he grabbed that little finger and bend it back and
whatever the fuck he was,
did he know what he's doing?
It's like magic.
He's like,
oh,
that little guy is going to get the shit kicked out of him and the other guy and
be like,
I ran,
I ran a wreck.
So,
um,
yeah.
Isn't that hilarious?
There's nothing worse than taking shit from somebody and you don't give them
shit back.
You know why?
Because 23 fucking laters years later,
it still bugs you.
You guys hit that.
There's a,
there's a great one.
If you guys want it,
you want it?
Yeah.
You want to know where the fuck is the word?
I'm trying to say.
If you want to participate in the podcast,
what's the law?
I want to find out what the longest,
like who the oldest person is on my podcast.
What's the longest you've held on to some shit.
All right.
There's one that was from 1987 88 at least 22 fucking years ago.
It still bugs me every once in awhile I'll just pop in my head.
Well,
why don't we watch some glasses?
Ah,
a novel idea.
Hey,
why don't we not live a life of fucking crimes so we don't have to go to jail?
You fucking piece of shit.
Yeah,
the fuck did you do to get in jail?
You'd dumb fucking idiot.
You do.
I bet you one of those guys who pulled his shirt over his fucking head and tried
to rob a seven 11 on a whim.
That was another thing before they had really good security camera.
So this asshole wasn't on America's dumbest criminals.
I really fucking hate that guy.
Still to this day.
I remember I had a math teacher one time and he goes,
he was asking questions and he goes,
for a number seven,
let's call on the dumbest kid in the room,
Bill Barr,
and it's still fucking bugs me.
That was like fucking 24 years ago.
You know what?
I think that that's what heaven is to me.
When I die,
I go to heaven.
And then there's just a line of fucking people that gave me shit throughout my
life and I never punched him in the face and they just come one at a time and I
blast them in the,
they say what they said to me then and I blast them in the face and it doesn't
even hurt my hand cause it's heaven,
you know?
And I always fucking win.
Um,
wow.
That's a lot of anger,
isn't it?
Okay,
let's plow ahead.
So I go,
all right sweetie,
let's fucking go up to the goddamn Mandalay bay.
I've never been there.
Yeah.
So anyways,
like I said,
it was,
it's run by one of the winners of Hell's kitchen or some shit.
And when the reality is,
is what I'm not realizing is,
um,
people who win that show,
I'm now really starting to believe like,
it's like last comic standing.
You go to go to the winner of last comic standing,
Oh,
this guy,
one last comic standing and then you're going to go see some open miker who's
got 10 fucking minutes of material.
I'm basing that on the first season.
I don't know who won the other fucking seasons,
but it's a reality show.
So I imagine it,
it,
it's,
it's a fucking,
I dunno,
somebody with like a fucking Hula hoop going around their head.
Somebody with some sort of hook.
God knows that's how this business works.
You gotta have a hook,
know if anything told me that it was,
uh,
looking at the people headlining in Las Vegas.
And that's not true.
There's actually some real comedians out there.
George Wallace.
I know Bobby Slayton worked out there for awhile.
There was real comics out there,
but the guys who make the big fucking bucks,
they just do shit.
Well,
you know,
Uf puppets,
how the fuck is that still entertaining in 2010?
You know,
like what I can't do ventriloquism
is that right?
Ventriloquism is that the right word?
You won't hear me talk without moving my fucking lips.
I can do that shit a there.
They had dummy.
What did you do today?
Yeah.
Fuck.
You'll fail your Dar than I am.
Isn't that funny?
Huh?
That dummy thing.
You're fucking dumb now.
Wait,
I've got to have a stupid voice,
right?
Take it to another level.
Who Do,
who could go Google dude.
Fucking sold out shows at Caesars.
10 million a year entertainer of the year.
Bill Barr and fucking ham face.
Whatever the fuck you're fucking puppet is.
Why is the fucking puppet always smarter?
Can't somebody switched that up?
I'd be arguing with my puppet second.
The puppet started giving me shit.
Oh really?
You're so fucking smart.
What if I take my hand out of your back now look at you.
He just fell on your wooden face,
didn't you?
You dumb.
Fuck.
And I turned on the crowd.
What the fuck is wrong with you people?
What is it?
The 1930s.
She when you want,
what do you want me to do after this?
She was,
what's my fucking encore?
Come out here and do the Goddamn Charleston.
Yeah.
Charleston.
I could even say it.
All right.
25 whispering minutes in.
I'm actually starting to get a louder,
but you know what?
The Sun is a little higher in the sky.
They liked that.
Did I sound like a native American?
Um,
anyways,
uh,
so let Jesus Christ,
let's get to the fucking Mandalay bay.
So we go over to the Mandalay Bay and Oh yeah,
that,
that's what I'm realizing that I'm eating at an open miker is fucking
restaurant.
I didn't even realize that until afterwards.
I eat the Burger.
I got one of the Kobe beef burgers.
All right,
now let me say something positive about Mandalay bay.
Uh,
before I get out of that,
they had some fucking insane shows coming up at their house of Blues.
All right.
Joe Rogan friend of this podcast and uh,
he had me on his podcast last week.
Joe Rogan is going to be performing there on July 3rd at Mandalay Bay at the
house of Blues the day before the,
uh,
the big UFC fight you off.
Sure job.
You're triple the woo.
Um,
do you ever see that Joe Rogan video,
the buffer three 60.
You got to see that just to fucking search that there's a fucking,
I don't know if it's a youtube video or if it's just on his,
uh,
website,
Joe rogan.net per check.
That one out.
Really fucking funny video.
But anyways,
he's playing there and lamb of God,
if you're into that,
a tolerable sort of death metal,
that guy still sings in that fucking uh,
you know,
Tom waits voice.
Tom Waits is really the father of death metal if you listened to is the way that
guy sinks on a out,
you know,
or maybe Louis Armstrong and then it goes Louie Armstrong,
Tom Waits and then fucking death metal.
Nah,
I see trees of green red roses too.
Um,
anyways,
so that's the good shit at Mandalay bay.
The bad shit is we go to this fucking burger place,
I can't even remember the name of it.
We go in there and I order a $16 and 50 cent fucking Coby beef burger and
they're talking about how it's the greatest Goddamn Burger.
I'll,
you know,
the highest quality fucking meat,
Yadda,
fucking Yada.
My girl orders one to 16,
15,
16,
50.
What is that?
Kids,
that's 33 bucks plus fries plus drinks,
all that bullshit.
You know,
the mob doesn't run Vegas anymore.
You can't go out and get yourself a $2 stake.
The whole fucking place out there now as a God damn,
it's a fuck over.
So whatever cost me like 40 something bucks,
50 bucks with the goddamn tip,
I eat it.
You know,
it wasn't even that good.
My girls like,
how's your burger?
You know what I said?
I said,
it's good just keeping the peace,
keeping the water nice and smooth.
Nice and fucking still on the horizon.
Okay.
So anyways,
I get back to my hotel.
My girl already tells me she doesn't feel too good at that burger sitting in or
like a Goddamn boot.
And I'm like,
you know what?
I feel fine.
I get ready to do my show,
iron my button down shirt,
put a little conditioner in my hair,
what's left of it,
shape it up a little and I head downstairs to go work the Orleans casino,
the last place,
Carlin ever the place where the smothers brothers retired,
you know,
smothers brothers who was so fucking edgy,
they actually lost their sketch show during the Vietnam War.
They did sign,
I forget what the sketch was,
but they had the balls to say no to the network.
And Do,
uh,
a sketch that was actually criticizing what the fuck we were doing over there
and they lost their goddamn show.
You know,
I don't know about you guys,
but for me,
that's lifetime respect.
So anyways,
I walked down there and I'm going through the Orleans casino and then all of a
sudden it just fucking hits me.
Boom,
right in my stomach.
Like some capsule,
some time release.
CIA,
you're going to shit your pants fucking capsule goes off.
And I know there is no question that whatever I just ate was not good for my
body.
And it was about to reject it one way or the other without getting crude people,
when something goes into your stomach,
if it's coming out,
it only has two options.
All right.
Anyways,
I just thought of a really,
really bad joke for the fucking third one,
and I'm not going to say it,
but it involved stabbing yourself in the stomach and you can fill in the blanks
on that one.
All right.
So anyways,
um,
Tommy,
he gotta be fucking,
you gotta be shitting me,
no pun intended.
So I go in the back way.
The same way that Carlin used to go in,
cause I've already taught,
asked everybody every fucking question literally is how much I'm into Carlin.
How did he leave?
Did he hang out now?
We'd say good night.
And he would go right out the door and he'd be in the car and he wasn't
difficult to work with.
I guess he had arthritis at the end of his life.
And uh,
the sound guy was saying one show,
he forgot to take the bottle caps off the water bottles and he saw the car loan
was struggling with them and when he got off because George,
I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry George.
Just like whack man.
AL,
come on,
come on.
I don't give a shit that worry and just walked out.
I guess.
He was a really great guy.
So anyways,
I'm walking through this legendary door
and uh,
you know,
and what's worse is like,
I know what's going to happen,
but I know it's not going to happen for like another 15 minutes.
And coincidentally the fucking show starts in 15 minutes and I'm going on first.
All right.
And this guy,
when you're backstage literally says 20 minutes til show time,
20 minutes til show time.
He like counts it down.
I never get nervous before shows,
but this guy counting down the show is making me nervous.
15 minutes till showtime.
Okay.
And it's starting to get worse and fuck it.
Get literally gets down to two minutes before showtime.
And I'm questioning,
can I make it through a half set?
And I was like,
you know what?
Fuck this.
The show can't start without me.
My opening music is Elvis Presley.
Anyways,
the fuck do I care?
They can listen to that song I'm going robe with Google's lose your long blur.
Her
slam before,
conform yourself.
The fucking sink.
A Ho,
Ho Hoo.
I don't give a shit.
And I said fuck it.
And I fucking ran into the bathroom.
And a,
I will spare you the details,
but you know,
when something either amazing
or uh,
something amazing happens,
they make a statue.
If something horrific happens,
a lot of times they will preserve the area.
You know,
like Dealey Plaza fucking president gets his brains blown out.
All of a sudden.
We can't change one blade of fucking grass.
The horror that happened in that fucking bathroom,
ladies and gentlemen,
I never do shit jokes.
They should have retired that fucking bathroom.
That's it.
They should've just fucking,
uh,
air sealed it and just put a glass fucking door.
Two people could look in,
in,
and realize why they closed that fucking burger joint at the Mandalay bay.
And,
uh,
I got to met.
Dude,
I haven't,
this is Monday.
I'm finally back to normal.
So there you go.
There's my big shit story.
I had a burger over at the fucking Mandalay bay and it almost ruined my fucking
show over at the Orleans.
So if you guys saw me,
anybody saw me Saturday night.
All right,
you want to talk about a professional because I extra fucking killed on that
show.
If you knew what the fuck happened,
just know that the next time you go to Vegas and you go to see Barry Manilow and
he's singing that song.
Mandy,
you something you've summed and then you sat there,
but I still want to fuck you.
Oh,
Mandy.
Right.
Just know that he could have just been shitting his fucking brains out two
minutes before he put on his ray on fucking slacks with his horrific plastic
surgery is yanked back face.
I bet you know I was going to say he d and another face lift if he fucking shit
the way I did before my show.
But that's actually not true.
There's no strain.
There was no straining.
Um,
anyways.
All right bill.
Jesus Christ.
Enough already.
So anyways,
one of the things I like to do when I go out to Vegas as I like to check out
some of the acts that are out there,
because Las Vegas is a viable option for a standup comedian.
Um,
if things aren't going well for you in,
uh,
in Hollywood,
but you're a huge draw is you can actually go out there like,
uh,
you know,
some of the comedians that are out there,
I won't name names,
but they're making a ridiculous amount of money,
you know,
3 million,
four,
five,
$7 million contracts
for the year.
And you don't have to travel,
you don't have to go on the road or nothing.
And believe me,
I have thought about it.
I've thought about it.
It's like you fucking kidding me.
4 million.
I'd stay out there for a year.
I just do it.
I get a fucking,
I think I already talked about this.
I'd have a,
a,
this is how I had a plan.
I was going to have a fucking,
a really fucking slamming house that I would rent and then I would make the
casino,
give me a car service and I would just have him pick me up,
drive me to the Gig,
walk right in the back door,
like Carlin do my show and walk.
That's probably why I did it.
I fucking walked right back out,
give me the car and I get the fuck outta there,
you know,
that way I wouldn't get sick of the casinos or any of that type of shit or at
least it would take longer.
But someone was telling me that Celine Dion actually has it down and yes,
I am comparing myself to Celine Dion.
Cause sometimes,
I don't know if you guys notice when I'm really feeling a joke,
I start punching myself in the chest.
Um,
her fucking music is horrific.
She's like the white version of Beyonce,
you know,
where she's really successful.
I'd actually fucker,
but the sound of her voice makes me want to just fucking kill myself,
you know?
I mean how hard is Beyonce?
But her voice is fucking,
it's beyond horrific.
It's like,
it's unacceptable.
Doesn't she sound like she's singing like two octaves higher than she should be?
Okay.
The worst is when you're in like a restaurant and they just have it on.
It's sort of low volume and the background and you're like,
is someone choking on their food?
Actually that would make sense because that would mean that you could actually
get air out.
Is somebody sort of choking on their food?
Is there a an s and m couple
in the corner booth
and the dude is applying just enough pressure.
All right.
Whatever.
Um,
anyway,
she had it down the best.
Celine Dion like she would live,
she had a helicopter pick her up at her fucking house.
She land on top of the casino.
Right?
You guys don't understand that.
How much of a dream this is,
any performer who's listening to this is fucking is got a fucking hard on at
this point.
This is the ultimate.
All right.
Other than just having a fucking evil twin robot who always kills and just goes
out and does your shows,
you know,
and the
fucking helicopter would pick her up at the house,
Flyer over to the casino,
land on top of the casino,
and then she would just go down,
go out,
sing,
punch herself in the chest and then just fucking get back on the helicopter and
ride back.
Do you realize that means she was doing her vocal warmup in like our bathroom,
you know,
and like five seconds later or whatever as she sat in her kitchen eating fucking
fruit loops or some shit.
You know,
toto,
20 hit the fucking
sound of those helicopter blades out,
dude.
I,
we'd be listening to the theme from Mash.
Bad,
bad at and a,
you know,
or maybe some of that music that they listened to when like apocalypse now.
What were some of the music that they listened to?
Was that the one at one of those war movies where they would listen to the
doors?
This is the end Doodoodoo my Olay Freddy.
And you probably wonder why bill,
what the fuck are you singing so much for
on your podcast this week?
I'll tell you why.
Because,
uh,
I went out to Vegas and uh,
I saw a group out there that was selling out and it was frustrating to me how
much people like singers.
This group had the worst fucking name
of any group I've ever seen in my life.
I right,
it was four people,
three guys and one girl.
All with like the fucking face lifts face yanked back to fucking hair dyed all
well into their 50s except for one of them who might've been 38.
And I thought they were an acapella group.
They're not,
they sing and they have a band there and the name of the group was vocal soup.
Vocal soup.
Is that not the most disgusting fucking name
you've ever fucking heard who came up with that vocal soup?
So I'm like,
I have to go.
I have to go on Youtube,
look them up,
look up vocal soup and click on vocal soup and concert
and I'm going to sing you some of their lyrics.
They sing vocals soup.
Yeah.
You take four cool voices and you make them high and he carried everything you
get.
You get vocal soup.
How fucking gross as that.
It just makes you gag just to think of it.
And the in the fucking lyrics,
they do nothing to try to make it less gross.
There's actually a line in that then they're stupid theme song that you won't
stop slurping till you're burping up focal soup and the end of the video,
I shit you not speaking of Shit,
which is the reoccurring theme of this podcast.
They actually have an animated bowl of soup that is shit Brown.
It looks like a bowl of fucking diarrhea.
I know it's gross,
but,
um,
I have to accurately describe it.
And they have notes coming out of it with the steam
vocal soup.
Ah,
it's fucking horrific vocal soup.
And this is what killed me is the one guy in the band,
the rocker is actually this guy from the group foreigner.
And it's just like,
okay,
whatever.
You know,
I dunno.
Foreign is broke up right now and you had a bad deal.
Some behind the music shit,
you need money a,
I respect it.
But how the fuck did you sign off on vocal soup?
Former person that was in Farner,
you know,
you didn't,
you didn't speak up like,
hey guys,
you know,
I don't want a big league anybody,
but I,
I wasn't a band that not,
not only sold out arenas,
not only had a number one record,
but I want it to say we actually had a pretty cool fucking name.
I think we can do better than vocal soup.
I mean,
I don't want to go the hacky route here with like what will be your,
the rube shoots,
what were the other options?
Throat Puke.
Ah,
fucking throat puke.
Yeah.
You won't stop yakking until you fucking burping up stomach acid.
It's fucking horrific.
But of course they sell out.
They sell out and everybody loves him.
And I guess the piano player worked with Frank Sinatra for 10 fucking years and
he also signed off on vocal soup.
Ugh.
It's just,
I dunno,
but they sell out,
you know,
that's what the fuck happens in Vegas.
And it really,
you know,
Vegas will really help you understand this business as a performer.
Like why good things don't make it and why shit makes it.
Oh,
you've got to do is fucking go out there,
you know,
put a fucking toilet seat on your head.
Toilet seat head.
Yeah.
If you don't have a toilet and you want to take a fuck and shit,
I'm all right.
I think that says I'm running out of fucking steam here.
Uh,
let's recommend some youtube videos here.
Um,
youtube video.
I already told you to check out vocal soup.
Oh,
it's just making me sick to my stomach to continue to say that name a youtube
video.
Look up.
Best cry ever.
MMM.
It's unbelievable.
And then of course,
you gotta hit the auto tune remix of it.
It really is the best,
uh,
one ever.
But don't look at the Popeye's chicken one.
I hate when they people do those,
that racist Shit,
you know.
Um,
anyways,
um,
and then there's another one.
This is just an uncomfortable podcast.
I talked to you about my bodily functions.
I brought up vocal soup and just for the Trifecta of disgusting,
it's usually not,
it's never been this disgust.
And this,
this,
I'm going to nominate this one for the most disgusting podcast of all time.
Um,
and this is the cherry on top here at the last youtube video,
uh,
is chimp rapes frog.
It's really fucking,
I actually had to shut it off.
I had to shut it off.
Um,
it started off is sort of funny and then it's bizarre.
And then the people in the background who are filming it are so fucking dumb
that you,
you can't,
uh,
I dunno.
They just,
he just listened to them.
And you hear that their parents and you know,
you realize why we shouldn't have tried to stop the swine flu,
swine flu.
I can't even talk.
Sorry.
I'm tying to talk and type at the same time.
And here's something new.
Here's,
here's the fucking cool old car
of the week.
Go on.
Um,
go on youtube and look up a Nash Metropolitan.
Now I'm sure people made fun of this and you're going to be like,
of course you like this car bill because you drive a fucking Prius,
which you got to check this.
This car was a fucking Badass car.
When they will make an all these huge cars back in the day,
they made this little fucking car.
I don't know.
Check it out.
Tell me what you think about it.
Some people like redid theirs.
Um,
I know it's not a fucking Mclaren.
Don't be a cunt.
Just check it out.
It's a cool fucking car.
Um,
by,
uh,
international,
I guess national international is somehow combined or something.
I don't know what happened.
They became American motors.
I really should have looked that part up.
Puts a fucking cool car.
It's got three on the tree,
you know,
you know the old school cars where you had like the uh,
the,
uh,
if it was an automatic,
the park neutral,
reverse drive,
all that shit was right on the steering column.
Uh,
I think last time they made a car with,
if it was at,
it was a standard and you shifted up there.
They called it three on the tree and I'd never even heard of that until I was
like fucking 25 years old because those cars were long gone.
But this thing,
three on the fucking tree,
check it out,
a Nash Metropolitan.
And you know what that's going to be it for the whispering podcast this week.
And maybe it was a good thing that I whispered it because it was so fucking
disgusting.
Let me,
uh,
let me hype some of my gigs coming up here.
Uh,
let me go to the official website of bill.
I'm going to be a,
the next kick I have.
I'm not working again until,
uh,
I actually have a July 12th on my website,
but I have to change that.
I don't get to Montreal till the 13th people.
July 13th through the 17th.
I'm going to be in Montreal,
Canada.
Speaking of cities that riot after they win or lose,
just like Los Angeles,
another sports town of fucking animals who attack police officers and tip over
cars,
even if they fucking win,
win or loose.
Um,
I'm going to be up at the Montreal comedy festival,
the just for laughs festival.
I'm doing my new one hour of material.
So while you fucking frogs up there,
who want to pretend like you're from Paris,
I'm speaking of that shit.
Uh,
I love the,
uh,
my actually gonna burn a job,
Burnett show.
How many fucking listeners do I have?
Actually,
you know what,
my,
uh,
the guy who actually set up my entire,
a podcast player told me a week ago that as of the beginning of this month told
me this a week ago,
I had 1 million,
3000 something downloads of my podcast.
Do you want a,
do you fucking understand that for a second?
Let's think about that for a second.
If I charged a dollar a podcast,
I wouldn't have to do this fucking podcast anymore.
That's actually bullshit.
First of all,
people wouldn't have,
you know,
I know a lot of people go back and they download all 150.
And if it was a buck a piece they wouldn't,
but if I charged a dime a piece,
I would add a hundred grand,
hundred fucking grand,
you know,
that's almost as much as focal soup makes a night.
All right.
So anyways,
maybe I'll do that.
Maybe I'll charge like a fucking dime.
Cause if you didn't notice from the,
uh,
from the story I was telling you about working Vegas and not having to do the
road and that type of thing,
that's what happens to perform is after awhile is it's not the doing of the
show.
It's the fucking travel and you try to figure out how the fuck I can get off the
road.
Initially the road seems like a cool,
fun thing to do when it is,
but then as you get older and you've been pretty much everywhere,
uh,
you try to look for ways.
What'd you guys do?
If I charge 10 cents now,
what would that be?
10 cents.
You guys are really going to expose me for how dumb I am.
That means you can download the entire podcast for 53 fucking years for 15
bucks,
you know,
be $15.
I'd have a hundred grand in my pocket.
Granted it would go down to like fucking 50 after the Goddamn government came
in.
But you know what?
You know what that would do?
That would buy me a nude fucking dodge challenger.
The fucking top of the line,
one with the fucking stripe on it and shit.
Um,
don't worry,
I'm not,
I'm not going to charge a dime,
but what I am going to do is I'm going to start,
I'm,
I'm at the beginning of guilting you guys into buy my new DVD.
Okay?
Just for the simple fact,
dad,
I don't charge for this motherfucker.
I am real.
I am.
I am going to let you guys know that I'm going to guilt you motherfuckers.
All right,
pay it forward.
And it's not that you can't just buy one of my DVDs.
You got to buy two,
one for yourself to show all your friends and then you've got to buy the second
one for somebody that you don't really like,
but you have to buy him a gift.
It's a great fucking gift.
You know your boss,
you have conti fucking sister in law,
you know,
and you have to get him a gift cause they get you a gift as that's a great gift
to get is my fucking DVD.
It's only fucking 20 bucks.
There you go.
You can't shut your face and watch this guy trash women for an hour.
Um,
that's it everybody.
That's the podcast for this week.
I uh,
apologize that it was so fucking graphic.
I usually don't tell shit stories,
shit jokes,
bodily feel fluid stories.
But uh,
it happened.
What do you want from me?
But anyways,
I want to thank the Orleans casino if I have on me.
I had a fucking great time.
If you go out to Vegas,
go to the Orleans casino,
you know,
if you a little more mature and you don't want to deal with those fucking whores
walking around.
Oh Hey,
I gotta,
I gotta give you guys the name of this fucking thing.
I actually,
I'm not one of these guys who's into art.
Really.
Bill,
you just did a fucking shit joke for fucking 45 minutes.
You guys,
next time you go out to Vegas,
go out to the Peter Lick.
Um,
gallery gallery,
Peter Lik L.
I k this guy takes pictures of,
of uh,
like beautiful scenes in nature and he uses this camera from like the 1930s that
it literally takes a minute for the camera to take a picture.
And obviously,
I don't know shit about photography,
but I don't know what he does.
He opened something,
it's wide open and he hits it.
And because it takes so long to take the picture,
it gets all these unbelievable colors.
It literally looks like an HD TV picture.
And,
uh,
they stick you in these rooms and with these dimmers and what they do is they
dim the lights down.
You,
it looks like the sun is going to,
I can't explain it,
but there they have a gallery in Mandalay bay,
the Venetian and the,
uh,
that mall,
that covered mall there
at Caesar's palace.
Definitely check that out.
If you're going out to Vegas,
Peter Lik,
you know when you're done checking out Joe Rogan at the House of Blues July 3rd,
go to the,
uh,
all you could do that.
Go up there.
Don't get a hamburger.
Check out the Peter Lick,
uh,
pictures and have them sit you down
in one of the,
in one of the rooms and have them dim the fucking lights to check it out,
man.
Peter Lik,
man,
it's the shit.
All right.
That's it.
I hope it was funny.
I hope it was a funny podcast.
I felt a little fucking hampered by the fact I had to whisper here.
Yeah.
But,
uh,
what the hell did I do?
Did I just shut this fucking thing off?
No,
I didn't.
All right,
you guys.
Everybody have.
All right,
I'll talk to you next.
[inaudible] [inaudible] fucking wild.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].